South Africa's ruling ANC party has
condemned a wave of attacks against
immigrants that's left at least six
people dead it's the first official
criticism of the violence that's
targeted businesses and homes owned by
foreigners in the southern city of
Durban despite a heavy police presence
when they bring Mozambique is planning
to help some of its citizens leave the
city after Malawi announced its own
repatriation plan on Monday earlier we
asked the journalist Romanian khazaei
why this violence has flared up now the
violence started two weeks ago
apparently after their zulu king king
quit was really teeny made a speech
where he actually said I'm all
foreigners in kwazulu-natal she packed
their bags and indeed the province and
leave the country in the same and we saw
flare-ups in different townships were
outta case it in such as Amla z which is
the biggest Township ER for housing over
a million people here a number of
foreign nationals were beaten up some
were killed and we've got reports of
five that were told so far and many of
the shops were looted many of them were
forced to leave and which is obviously
called a lot of animals did a lot of
volatility this isn't the problem
there's competition between the locals
and the foreigners apartment Nationals
are very good at uniting and ensuring
that there could be succeed we've seen
many Somalis nationals who are very
successful businessman and they go into
the townships they allocate a favorable
location where they can set up their
shops they good at stop taking and
they're very professional in terms of
managing their businesses so we're
seeing many South African nationals who
are seeing this prosperity amongst the
foreign nationals and um some of them
are quite resentful of it and others
just actually share Jennifer big as any
phobic mindset which even though they're
not in competition with these foreign
nationals they actually do not want him
here so those are the competing
narratives that are that are prevalent
Sharon vs. itself
you